señor frenkel bienvenida france24 tras
el pedido de la fiscalía hemos podido
ver como cristina fernández sigue
levantando grandes pasiones entre parte
de los argentinos de dónde viene esta
defensa tan férrea hacia su figura y que
representa para sus seguidores
bueno cristina fernández es una de las
figuras más importantes de la política
argentina sino diría la más importante
en términos de de primero por el que es
una de las figuras más populares
en términos de apoyo de la ciudadanía
argentina y además porque es un eje
estructural del sistema político
argentino es decir no solo es una de la
figura más importante del gobierno es un
gobierno que podríamos calificar una
suerte de coalición sino que además la
oposición también se estructura en
función de un fuerte antikirchnerismo
y en ese marco además cristina es una
figura muy popular
en términos de una lidereza carismática
con una gran cantidad de seguidores que
diría que muy pocos o casi ningún otro
dirigente tienen argentina con esa
capacidad de movilizar miles de personas
se ha hablado usted del antikirchnerismo
de la oposición también del carisma de
la propia christina pero muchas veces
aparece la figura de su difunto marido
el también ex presidente néstor kirchner
y de eva perón son figuras de las que
habla continuamente la ex presidenta
como se asocia su éxito al recuerdo de
estas otras dos figuras tan potentes
dentro del progre argentino
para que el propio periodismo es un
movimiento que tiene una tradición
que se ordena en función de fuertes
liderazgos
liderazgos carismáticos
digamos en ese sentido eva perón junto
con ese momento juan perón fueron parte
de veamos desde los que inauguraron esta
tradición y néstor kirchner junto con
otras figuras en otros momentos la
historia han sido también el líder el
peronismo y figuras que han sabido
debemos transformarse en líderes
populares entonces en ese sentido
cristina es parte de esa transición que
tiene el peronismo como un movimiento
popular de masas
organizado en general alrededor de
fuertes liderazgos
si esto es un fenómeno netamente
argentino o se enmarca dentro de las
dinámicas del populismo latinoamericano
habrá que ver con qué otros países se
comparan no me parece que
digamos
si uno compara por ejemplo con brasil o
con méxico o con chile que serían país
es más o menos comparables con argentina
por el sentido argentina tiene esa
particularidad no no ha habido tal vez
estar esos movimientos con esos líderes
en
el resto los países o habido líderes
pero que no perduraron su tradición su
partido su movimiento como es el caso
argentino por lo cual ahí me parece hay
una particularidad argentina que tiene
que ver con con características propias